hidden in the microverse all around you
there's a merciless war being fought by
the true rulers of this planet
microorganisms
amoeba protists bacteria archaea and
fungi compete for resources and space
and then there are the strange horrors
that are viruses hunting everyone else
not even alive they are the tiniest most
abundant and deadliest beings on earth
killing trillions every day not
interested in resources only in living
things to take over
also we thought
turns out there are giant viruses that
blur the line between life and death and
other viruses hunting them
[Music]
considerably smaller than your cells or
even bacteria viruses are nothing but a
hull a tiny bit of genetic material and
a few proteins
no metabolism no way to propel
themselves no will or ambition
they float around aimlessly and hope to
stumble upon a victim to infect and take
over
viruses are so simple that we're not
sure if they should count as living
things or not
some scientists argue viruses are alive
others think that the cells they infect
are the actual living viruses hybrid
organisms called viral cells and the
viral particles are more like seeds or
spores
and many others think viruses are just
dead
material the origin of viruses is a
mystery because how can something that
needs victims to make more of itself
emerge in the first place
there are many ideas
viruses may have been essential steps in
the emergence of life or maybe they
started out as escaped dna from cells
that became really good at making copies
of themselves
maybe they are the descendants of truly
lazy parasites that let others do all
the work for them
the current thinking is that viruses
probably emerged multiple times from
different origins but we simply don't
know for sure yet
whatever the truth is viruses are the
most successful beings on this planet
there's an estimated 10 000 billion
billion billion viruses on earth if we
put them all next to each other they
would stretch for 100 million light
years 500 milky way galaxies wide
very recently viruses became even
weirder when scientists found a
completely new type
giant viruses nicknamed gyrus
not only did it break all sorts of
records but questioned many assumptions
we had about their nature
gyruses even come with their own
parasites virophages
viruses that hunt other viruses which
seemingly makes no sense at all
and since we identified the first one in
2003 it seems like these giants are
everywhere we look in the oceans in
water towers in the guts of pigs and the
mouths of humans
and they're even weirder than we thought
gyruses look funny like hairy geometric
forms or mini pickles much larger than
all viruses we knew before which
explains how they could hide in plain
sight for centuries scientists saw them
under their microscopes and just thought
they had to be bacteria it's like
suddenly discovering there are
elephant-sized ducks everywhere
most gyruses we've found so far hunt
amoebi and other single-celled beings
when they find a victim they connect
with it and use its natural processes to
enter the cell
like all viruses their goal is to
misappropriate the victim's
infrastructure and procreate
imagine a mouse crawling into your mouth
and using your guts and bones and fat
tissue to build a mouse factory
the gyrus unloads its attack proteins
and genetic material and rearranges the
cell from the inside
its structural elements protein
production machinery and large amounts
of mitochondria for energy are changed
to become an actual factory called
viroplasm
some gyruses even construct a membrane
to shield them from the cell's antiviral
defenses
once finished the viroplasm begins to
assemble new gyruses using the victim up
from the inside until it's filled up
finally the invader usually orders the
cell to self-destruct and releases new
gyruses to look for new prey
but what makes gyruses special is not
their modus operandi or their size even
it's that they are much more complex
than thought possible for a virus
your cells have around 20 000 genes
a typical bacterium has a few thousand
genes the coronavirus has around 15 hiv
or the flu around 10.
the number of genes alone is certainly
not everything the tomato for example
has 35 000 genes
but generally we think of life as a
complex system so below a certain
complexity level something may be closer
to dead material rather than a living
organism but gyruses can have hundreds
or even thousands of genes blurring the
line between living and dead things
and it's not just the numbers that are
special but also what these genes do
we used to think of viral genes as the
simplest of instructions just enough to
overcome the defense of their victims
and make new viruses
but many gyrus genes are completely
unique basically mystery genes
even more confusing a huge selection of
their genes that are actually hallmarks
of living things
genes that regulate nutrient intake
energy production light harvesting
replication or are just necessary to
keep cells alive
some recent studies have even suggested
that some gyruses with very complex
genomes may be able to maintain a basic
level of metabolism on their own which
if true will shake up what we thought of
viruses even more
we still don't know anything for sure
but one idea about gyrus genes is that
they might fundamentally alter the
physiology and evolution of their
victims by integrating their own genomes
and merging with them into chimeric
organisms
or the other way around take some host
genes with them and be changed
themselves
for billions of years gyruses may have
been existing alongside and infecting
cells exerting an unseen influence on
the development of life
not just as a parasite but jerking
evolution in different directions by
mixing genes around in all directions
which brings us to another unique thing
about them virophages the viruses
hunting gyruses
the concept itself is a bit
mind-boggling how can a thing that might
be dead hunt another thing that might be
dead too
let's look at one of them
the viruphage sputnik is hunting a gyrus
called mama virus that itself is hunting
amoebi
sputnik is a tiny minimalistic virus
that doesn't even have the genes and
tools to replicate itself
what it does have is the ability to
hijack the viroplasm factories of mama
viruses
so virophages need their victim the
gyrus to infect their victim an amoeba
first and then they can parasitize it
a memovirus viroplasm infected by
sputnik can only produce very few new
gyruses and among these many are
deformed and broken unable to infect
further cells instead it makes loads of
new sputnik viruphages
other virophages are even more subtle
when they infect a viroplasm they just
integrate their genetic code into the
newly produced gyruses like sleeper
agents
the next time one of these infiltrated
gyruses successfully infects a cell it
produces mostly viruphages instead of
gyruses
gyruses are not completely defenseless
though
a few years ago the world was in awe
when scientists discovered crispr a
bacterial defense system against viruses
it turns out some gyruses have a system
that might be similar a sort of gyrus
immune system against virophages
in turn virophages can also be used as
an antigyrus defense mechanism by living
cells
some protests have been found that
integrated the genetic code of
virophages into their genome and kept it
when the protists were infected by
gyruses they used the code to create
virophages themselves to take over the
gyrus factories in the end the protists
would still be killed by the gyrus
infection but instead of releasing
gyruses to kill its buddies it released
virophages to hunt them
the amazing thing about everything we've
told you in this video is that we're
still very much at the beginning
it's not even been 20 years since the
discovery of gyruses and virophages
there is so much going on in the
microverse
life is not an isolated event but a ping
pong game of trillions of organisms and
viruses
so when you feel down and like there's
not that much new to discover think of
gyruses and all the other elephant-sized
ducks all around us
invisible until we look more closely
but how do you learn to look at the
world like a scientist
the best way is by trying things out for
yourself
our friends from brilliant are the
perfect coaches to turn your curiosity
into practical skills
brilliant is a problem-solving website
and app that makes science accessible
with a hands-on approach
more than 60 interactive courses give
you the tools to crack problems in maths
computer science and engineering in a
way that feels more like playing a game
than doing homework
lessons will surprise you with
storytelling code writing tasks and
interactive challenges basically using
whatever keeps you interested and
entertained
the focus is on you having fun
learning something will happen almost
without you noticing it
and tiny step by tiny step you'll build
up your long-term understanding of
science and get closer to your stem
goals
to start looking at the world of science
for a different perspective go to
brilliant.org nutshell and sign up for
free
and there's an extra perk for kurzgesagt
viewers the first 200 people to use the
link get 20 percent off their annual
membership which unlocks all of
brilliant courses in maths science and
computer science
at quartz gazant we love to get to the
bottom of things brilliant can help you
go on that deep dive
[Music]
you